[Music]
Santa Monica Studios has spent the last
14 years showing us how angry Kratos is
what makes God of War for one of the
best ps4 games is how they characterize
and build off a character who's only
been able to hit one note for so long
Santa Monica studio turned it's brooding
protagonist into a multi-faceted complex
character
get in the boat boy to take a few steps
back God of War has always been about
spectacle in combat sure those games had
stories and they were entertaining in
their own right but that always felt
like the side dish while the fast-paced
gory combat was the main course you were
meant to feel empowered and what's more
empowering than killing God's not much
and that was the hook the God of War and
all his fury runs around murdering gods
of all shapes and sizes guilty and
innocent to exact his revenge and in the
mid-2000s that was rad the scale of
these battles were unlike anything that
had been done before Santa Monica studio
knew exactly what they were going for
and every God of War Games set the stage
with an epic cinematic battle you had to
kill the Hydra at the beginning of one
fight the Colossus of Rhodes into and
ascend Mount Olympus on the back of a
Titan in three fortunately after God of
War ascension is disappointing sales
Santa Monica studio took a break to
rethink the series
[Music]
fast forward to 2018 and we have a very
different god of war game a soft reboot
that ditches the character action of the
previous games in favor of an
over-the-shoulder third-person
Metroidvania style game along with the
more intimate perspective came a better
pace God of War
with a stronger emphasis on characters
in order to do that Santa Monica studio
use quite a few nifty narrative devices
to set up Kratos the first can be seen
at the very beginning remember how I
mentioned that every other god of war
starts with a bombastic opening that
cranks everything up to 11 before
anything really happens well God of War
4 does the opposite we see Kratos in a
quiet forest resting his hand on a tree
we don't climb a giant monster murder a
god or gora hydra Kratos cuts down a
tree and it's worth mentioning that
Kratos isn't using a woodcutter's axe
he's using the Leviathan axe sure we
haven't seen Kratos kill any gods with
this axe spoilers yet but this axe
wasn't made to cut down a [ __ ] tree an
X like that is meant to kill something
there's something so uneasy yet peaceful
about seeing the God of War a being with
unending rage cut down a tree this scene
alone tells us we should expect a very
different adventure and a very different
Kratos this time around the rhythmic
swinging of the axe sets a new pace for
the once furious warrior we wouldn't
really see a different side of Kratos
without the most important character in
the game betrayus now I can't think of a
better foil to the God of War than a
small child instead of being presented
with a character who's already lost
everything we are given a character with
something to lose at Reyes no matter how
much Kratos resists brings out sides of
him that we've never seen for once
Kratos is trying to control his anger
now it's God is up only fire
only fire when I tell you to fire he's
trying to be a good father and set an
example for the boy it's almost as if
he's trying to keep at Reyes from making
the same mistakes he made could the God
of War now be faced with regret
[Music]
another scene that probably would have
played out differently without a trace
is when they meet the world serpent if
this was 2004 Kratos would have gutted
that snake and eaten it for breakfast
but at Reyes a kid who loved to hear
stories about the Norse gods stops his
father it's friendly he says
throughout the game Kratos has
continually put in positions he normally
wouldn't be in thanks to at Reyes
another dwarf should know he is of no
consequence the boy is always quick to
help out one of the dwarves or the lost
souls scattered around the lake even
then
Kratos is still closed off but he's
reacting and responding to at races
questions and comments
this may seem small but imagine God of
War without the boy Kratos would be
quiet as a tree until he meets Mamere
and even then at Reyes was the one who
would always carry the conversations
however Kratos still plays his cards
close to his chest he holds on to a lot
of Secrets that he refuses to share with
the boy the boy will want answers that
will be my problem whatever you're
hiding you cannot protect him forever
this is where our prior knowledge of the
series comes in we know Kratos is a
murder and we know a trace as a god but
Kratos seems content to hold on to the
secret until his dying breath something
had to happen in order to get those
wheels spinning and something did
despite everything they had gone through
up until this point
dragons ogres draggers trolls and gods
the boy gets sick he gets sick because
he doesn't know who he is
he thinks he's mortal but his body is
trying to tell him he's a god this part
is kind of unclear but I was happy to
buy into it because this meant that
Kratos needed to come clean after all
this sickness wasn't caused by a monster
or the cruel wrath of a God but by
Kratos himself his own father for the
first time in the game Kratos is alone
we see his grief pain and torment on
display
Athena haunts him as he returns home and
he's forced to confront the past he's
hidden away for so long
what follows is one of the game's most
memorable scenes a scene I will be
talking about for years to come Kratos
must embrace his past if he wants to
save his son the very thing he's been
trying to protect at Reyes from is the
only thing that can save the boy
[Music]
Kratos learns that maybe the only way a
trace can be a better God is by telling
him the truth after all we learn from
our mistakes history is documented so we
don't make the same mistakes as our
forefathers sometimes the only way to be
better is to be familiar with both ends
of the spectrum you have to know what
lies beneath the surface if you want to
build a solid foundation
[Music]
[Applause]
this point forward
credo Senate races dynamic changes quite
a bit after 10 Plus hours Kratos comes
clean about who at race really is
however he warns the boy about the
responsibility of being a god and at
Reyes lets it get the better of him the
very thing Kratos feared is coming true
the boy is cocky and quick-tempered
Kratos his first attempt to rein him in
might be one of the most beautiful
scenes in the game and tears volt Kratos
grabs him by the shoulders comforting
him for the first time in a hushed tone
says we are not men we are more than
that the responsibility is far greater
and you must be better than me
understand
say it
you will be better
[Music]
our this weapon any weapon comes from
here but only when tempered by this
discipline the self-control of the one
who wields it that is where the true
strength of a warrior lies Kratos is
trying to teach at Reyes the thing he
himself has lacked for so long
self-control the power of this weapon of
any weapon comes from here but only when
tempered by this for a trace to be
better than Kratos he needs that key
ingredient discipline and Kratos his
lack of discipline is part of what
triggered the events of the original
trilogy the thread that was pulling us
from location to location was Kratos as
rage and now he's telling his son his
future the one that will carry the torch
long after he has passed to temper his
heart with his mind despite all of god
of War's testosterone-fueled bravado
over the past 14 years this quiet
intimate scene is the most powerful
moment in the series and only Kratos
with all his flaws and misguided past
could have delivered something as moving
as this unfortunately a tray of still
lacks context Kratos is saying these
things but he doesn't know why it's not
until the very end that a trace finds
out that Kratos killed his own father
this what it is to be a god
the reasons
some scaring their mothers their fathers
once again Kratos grabs him by the
shoulders and tells him that they are
not bound by the past a trace will not
make the same mistakes he did and they
will be the gods they choose to be not
the gods that are destined to make the
same mistakes over and over and over
again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
120-plus
hour-long tracking shot led to this very
moment Kratos has accepted his demons
and rather than embarking on a long
journey of revenge he helped his son
find himself I can't think of a more
beautiful redemption story than that we
should finish this journey while I still
have strength
[Music]